though you know much can get lost amid
the cacophony of perpetual phony outrage
and it can be hard to discern any one
bit of outrage from any other you've
probably still noticed over the last few
weeks that people on the left are very
angry at florida
and i mean they're always angry at
florida they're angry mostly that
florida is thriving while they live in
gray dreary cities covered in human
feces and used heroin needles so you can
hardly blame them for being a bit
envious but the professed reason for all
the anger towards florida this time in
recent days has been a particular piece
of legislation called the parental
rights and education bill
now even if you don't live in the state
it's worth tracking the story because
much can be learned from it i think and
especially from the reaction to this
bill so the law would bar schools from
discussing sexual orientation and gender
identity with kids in elementary school
and this has provoked
volcanic fury from the left who have
dubbed the legislation the don't say gay
bill
they claim that this is among other
things an attack on free speech
of course the idea that adults have the
free speech right to have inappropriate
sexual conversations with children
is the kind of thing that you'd expect
only pedophiles and perverts and
predators to argue for
and you would be right
and it's easy enough to understand why
gender identity shouldn't be discussed
in elementary school in fact it
shouldn't be discussed in any grade any
at any level because it's an incoherent
made-up concept invented not
coincidentally by a pedophile mad
scientist named john money who you're
well familiar with if you listen to this
show
gender identity is a religious doctrine
it's part of the left-wing creed it has
no basis in science or reality
now if a christian public school teacher
cannot stand in front of his class and
declare that jesus christ is lord and
savior and all students should accept
him into their hearts
then a leftist public school teacher
should not be able to stand in front of
his class and declare that boys can
magically become girls if they believe
it in their hearts
the left has for years shouted that we
must keep religion out of the classrooms
but as it turns out they only had
certain religions in mind which we've
known for a while but what about sexual
orientation
now it's at least coherence and
factually true to say that a person has
sexual urges which are generally
oriented one way or another in fact um
john money also coined the term sexual
orientation but at least in this case
there's it's it's
it's coherent you understand what's
being said
the question though is whether a
government employee
in the government education system
would ever have any valid reason to talk
to a nine-year-old about sexual urges
the answer to that question obviously is
no
the left says that not only do these
adults have good reason to talk about
sexual urges with prepubescent children
but even that they the adults have a
right to hold such discussions
to force them to refrain from talking
about their sexual urges with children
is to persecute them we're told
moreover it deprives the children of
something that they need
because children before the age of
puberty somehow need to talk about a
topic that they fundamentally won't be
able to understand
and which has nothing to do with any of
the academic subjects that they're going
to school to learn about
this is absurd for a lot of reasons but
the main one is that it goes the other
way around you aren't depriving children
of something
they need by refraining from having
inappropriate sexual conversations with
them in elementary school you're
depriving them of something you they
need when you do have those
conversations
namely you're depriving them of the
innocence of childhood
well uh one thing i could tell you as a
four-star chef myself um amateur chef
but i consider myself a four-star chef
your kitchen is not complete without
great kitchen knives and that's why you
need cami coda kamikota taps into more
than 800 years of traditional techniques
from honshu japan kamikota also uses
steel sourced from mills in japan and
each blade is crafted using techniques
that have been honed and perfected by
generations of knife smiths each knife
comes in a beautiful heavy duty ash wood
box and makes sure that the knife is
stored safely as well each kamikota
knife goes through a rigorous 19-step
process that takes several years from
start to finish to complete our expert
blade smiths forge and shape raw steel
into hearty blades uh polishing and
sharpening them to an excruciatingly
fine edge each knife is individually
inspected kamikoto is so confident that
their knives will work for you that each
knife comes with a lifetime guarantee
because of their single bevel edge
kamikoto knives can achieve an
unbelievably sharp edge you just can't
get with other knives they can cut
through your rib eye like butter that is
guaranteed
kamikoto is currently having a massive
extended new year sale and on top of
that sale you can get an additional 50
50 off any purchase you make with
discount code matt wall so click the
link below or go to kamikoda dot com
slash matt walsh and use promo code matt
walsh to save an extra 50 today
now leftists they they actually will
openly scoff
at the very idea of the innocence of
childhood they don't recognize that
there isn't any innocent child because
along with being acolytes of john money
even if they don't know their acolytes
of them they're also acolytes of alfred
kinsey and the other late 19th and early
20th century degenerates who claim that
children are sexual from birth
now that's false but it turns out this
was not a that this was not a
description it was a proscription
children are not naturally sexual from
birth but these quacks would try to
change that they wanted them to be
and they've been trying to change that
fact ever since
and to prevent them from doing so to
prevent the adults from doing that
from sexualizing childhood that is a
personal attack against them
we're told
which should really tell you something
and so should this
outrage was renewed over the weekend
after a new amendment was added to the
bill which according to all the
headlines would require schools to quote
out their students
now the idea of outing an elementary
school student doesn't even really make
any sense to begin with
but the way the headlines are written it
makes it sound like
teachers are required to investigate a
child's sexual preferences and then set
off some kind of alarm
you know pull an alarm and alert the
whole building if a kid turns out to be
gay
yet investigating sexual preferences is
exactly the sort of thing that the bill
forbids
that's what they're not supposed to be
doing
so the framing doesn't really make any
sense here
it turns out
when critics say outing
what they mean is that schools are
required to inform parents
and there's a difference there
so here's the article from the hill
it says a new amendment to florida's
don't say gay bill would require schools
to inform parents of their children's
sexual orientation within six weeks of
learning that the student isn't straight
nbc affiliate wfla reported on monday
the amendment was filed friday by the
bill's co-sponsor state representative
joe harding the bill which has gained
national attention and pushed back bars
educators in florida from talking about
sexual orientation or gender identity in
primary schools parents would be able to
take legal action against school
districts that they believe have
violated the measure
the original version of the legislation
required schools to inform families of
their child's lgbtq plus status but gave
an option for exemption for the outing
in cases where educators feared it could
lead to abuse neglect or abandonment the
amendment offers no such exception
yes it offers no such exception
because any such exception would
guarantee that no school would ever tell
any parent anything
because they could always simply claim
that they fear abuse at home
and this is especially true given that
the left considers it abuse
if a parent fails to accept that their
son is really a girl
or
that their girl is really you know a
non-binary pansexual chipmunk or
whatever
the point of this amendment
is not that schools ought to be digging
into a child's personal life and then
reporting back to the parents
that's close to the opposite of the
point
the point is simply that the schools
that would be the government
institutions
should not know more about a child than
his own parents do
i have a right to know
what my child is doing at school what
he's saying how he's behaving
how he's quote identifying
there should not be any secrets kept
between students and teachers
there especially shouldn't be any sexual
secrets kept between between students
and teachers
only in a culture fully succumbed to
madness could that concept be at all
controversial
now the reason that parents should know
this information
is that they have a right to know
my child is my child
i have a right to this kind of knowledge
about him
especially if it's knowledge that other
people have about him
but the other reason is that teachers
can't be trusted and there are great
many examples that could be marshalled
to prove this point but here's just the
latest this is i'll play for you a local
news report out of a california school
district about the sleeping arrangements
at a recent science camp listen
micah the parents tell us that their
children came home from camp they were
asking a lot of questions about gender
and pronouns the parents then reached
out to the camp director who told them
that counselors biological males who
identify as they them are permitted to
spend the night in cabins with the young
girls
in the parking lot of weaver elementary
school in los alamitos a group of
parents no parent should feel the way i
feel after knowing what could have
happened to my daughter upset by the
sleeping arrangements at a school
organized science camp i contacted the
school and i asked them if they were
able to confirm that there was not a man
actually sleeping in the same cabin as
the girls
they were not able to confirm that the
parents say their fifth grade girls told
them some of the biologically male
counselors at camp ali in san bernardino
identified as they them and spent three
nights sleeping in cabins with the young
girls they're asleep they use the shower
they
go to the restroom camp pally confirms
per california state law we place staff
in cabins they identify with
now the the parents would go on in that
clip to to stress that they're not
they're not accusing
uh the male adults uh the the teachers
of doing anything they're just saying
that they're uncomfortable with the
sleeping arrangements they're not making
any specific accusations
they're not they're not claiming for
example sexual abuse but um i think that
they ought to claim sexual abuse because
that is sexual abuse
in and of itself
even if no even if nothing else happened
other than what we're being told for
male adults
sleeping with 10 year old girls
that is abusive sexually
in and of itself
without the parents knowing
but they can do it because they identify
as they them
and this is supposed to make them less
of a threat somehow
by some incoherent grammatical
technicality
they discovered the right to have a
slumber party with elementary school
girls at science camp
the question is whether you trust these
sorts of people to have sexual
conversations with your children
do you trust them to have secrets with
your children
do you trust them at all with anything
well
obviously you shouldn't
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content